I I had to kiss a Scarlet had to kiss
Scarlett Johansson I mean come on you
imagine how horrible that was can you
imagine how old that was what we did
such a shame this was really terrible
lips and everything it must have been so
awful it was hell okay first of all
she was mean and then no what happened
was we did a shot before lunch and it
was like this nice little two shot that
ended in the kiss and it was really good
and we went to lunch and she and I both
thought it was over and she had some
garlic she ate like an onion sandwich
and she came in and Cameron Crowe had
set the camera up and it was like a
tight shot of the kiss and she goes oh